j'en retiens juste après six heures sous
l'eau salée sans monsieur yassine
belattar sur twitter justement
publiquement dit que j'ai une tête de
chameau une fête bunol est là et aucune
des belles aucune des belles âmes
antiraciste n'est là pour dire mais
c'est scandaleux j'aurais dit un truc
pareil
mais on mourait voler dans l'ip alors
regarder dans est-ce qu'on peut revoir
et de yassine s'il vous plaît vous la
mettez vous mettez le mauvais tweet
alors non mais non le tweet de yaizu
libre à celui là c'est toujours que tu
dois celle qui dit dit voilà alors parce
que vous avez dit yassine belattar avec
ta tête de chameau qui se permet
d'insulter la terre entière les insultes
racistes tu ose encore la ramener quand
et insulté par le type de nocibé parce
qu'on reviendra là dessus aussi b la
marque de cosmétiques tu aurais pu avoir
la décence de la fermer mais bon
l'islamisme et yassine est un génie jean
messia c'est même plus même plus marrant
t3 rap pour les fachos était trop
raciste pour les arabes
ta place est entre les deux égaré que tu
es avec ta tête de l'eau combes
quant à marine voilà alors j'en ai c'est
baroque tout le monde sato trouve ça
drôle en signant deux hommes ont été
obligés de porter un film de la france
pour qu'on sache que tu es français
toujours se ressemblent car mon cousin
du lycée biceps c'est encore racisme et
ses deux petits fils tué un raciste
c'est l'adn de l'islamisme tué environ
oui mais tu vas rap c'est pas ça c'est
que tu considères les personnes qui sont
assimilés quasiment comme étant des
traîtres et moi je sens en moi je
considère lé inverse c'est à dire que tu
vis en france tu as la nationalité
française
le fait de pâtes comporter comme un
français parce qu'il ya une identité
française comme il ya une identité
marocaine communauté in hand identité
algérienne
le fait de pâtes comporter conformément
à l'identité du pays dont tu portes la
citoyenneté fait de toi un traître mais
pas celui qui s'érige en regardant je te
vraiment soyons objectifs on regarde
juste une question de quoi tu tenais ou
mais c'est pas la question des néons
c'est pas la question tenait où je suis
né au caire tu arrives à quel âge à
garder huit ans de plus que moi mais
c'est pas c'est pas la question à moi je
suis né en france mais ce n'est pas la
fonction en place on a le goût de la
question d'écouté
les écouter bon déjà déjà déjà un tu me
do on se vouvoie on se tutoie pas un
couard est voilà donc ces jeux leur dire
un truc qui va pas de plaire pour tout
un tas de raisons tu connais la
principale on n'a pas gardé les cochons
ensemble
et bah c'est bien la preuve que tu es
assis me voilà ce que je garde pas des
cochons
voilà exactement comme c'est ce que je
te dis c'est que ces études c'est
pourquoi parce que je garde des choses
et tu sais que tu sais pourquoi et je
garde mes chèvres pardon d'être
assimilée à la france quand tu vis en
france
excuse moi mais le niveau légal mais il
ne peut pas éliminer si vous le voulez
parce que j'aime beaucoup notre langue
et il s'avère que l offre plein de niort
gilles gard mais le vouvoiement toi mans
madame bonbon rose bref juste vous dire
quelque chose on cherche un bon bout
c'est moi vous êtes assimilés pas vous
n'êtes pas celle qui s'enfonce au fur à
mesure de l'émission est magnifique avec
son tailleur et oui non mais vous irez
la mélodie non de manière est ce que
vous me dites aurait bon vous voyez la
considération qu'il a pour les femmes
vous êtes là je veux dire je suis menacé
de mort vous me dites parti je mets un
foulard aux comment faites-vous le genre
je finis avec jean parce qu'on sait
jamais vu et là c'est un moment speed de
la zone vous aviez vous étiez jamais vu
l'élève ou finie la guerre tu te rends
pas mes frères vous étiez jamais vu et
ghazi donne et lui que je voulais vendre
la wii
yazid alger moi qui habite à la wii
[Applaudissements]
moi pour moi je vois pas je me suis je
dit la vérité
pour moi je vois ni camp parce que t'es
pas français mais non voilà c'est super
c'est pas parce que vous le dites que je
le suis plus mais non il s'avère que moi
je suis français tout le temps j'aime la
france de dunkerque à marseille j'ai
menacé
bah c'est dommage ça s'entend pas et ça
ne se voit pas mais j'aimerais bien
mettre à un pis mais moi j'en doute pas
la question que vous m'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous êtes nés ou mais quand on
arrive en france et comprend la
nationalité d'un pays c'est bien pour
devenir membre de la communauté
nationale de ce pays oui si vous voulez
rester ce que vous êtes resté ce que
vous êtes dans votre pays voilà mais
j'ai bien lu voilà c'est le jean que les
champs moi j'ai pas envoyé de papier
pour être français
mais lorsque vous avez fait c'est pas
les a renvoyés non la maison parce que
ça fait vraiment assimilé
mais si ça peut nous on va dire vous
volez cia voler comme comme messi avec
arrêt vous voulez que je vous dise
pourquoi j'ai changé de prénom
allez j'ai changé de prénom pour entrer
au point que parce que la mouvance la
mouvance que vous représentez de manière
très subtile pour vous en régie pour
vous il représente un niveau bas les
frères musulmans et bien effectivement
battant des cantons tous quand on
soutient le ccf de sava voilà voilà
quand vous le souhaitez de s'essayer
vous n'allez pas me dire vous êtes
membre du crif n'a faut arrêter les
conneries
ben alors voilà je ne sais pas là vous
parlez de 6 am soutenez les s'essayait
entre parenthèses le ccr pour tous les
attentats qui ont eu lieu islamiste n'a
eu un bon challenge
non mais quant à vous vous égarez la
médiation logo jean messia genre et sa
soupe et dont on parle pas du crif sinon
jean luc mélenchon va encore dire une
connerie
donc c'est bon il en natation de gens en
ont assez vite comme ça jean luc
mélenchon qui reste c'est dire que le
crif qui représente que lui-même
non mais jean-luc mélenchon résidence on
a voulu de la ville il a dit jean luc
mélenchon que c'était pas ça
sérieusement sa meilleure sortie je
pense qu'il aurait mieux fait de rester
chez villefranche il est meilleur avec
les huissiers à huy hà tinh je comprends
que j'essaie de répondre aux enjeux je
confirme par des dorés points mais je
comprends parfaitement qu'un mec que moi
constitue dans son logiciel une sorte de
bugs
11 38 on va dire ça c'est à dire c'est à
dire oui exactement bah oui puisque tu
l'a initié à l'autre ariane soucis et
moi je t'aime tu es mon frère m mcg la
france ni balade moitié-moitié pas mon
frère parce qu'on a aucun lien famille
laissez-nous hommage à constituer on
espère genre qu'est ce que vous
reprochez à l'asim pélata alors il y à
dents dans la lecture des frères
musulmans de l'islam alors je suis pas
frères musulmans moi je sais que tu
seras rebond également mais sans viser
je t'ai pas parler fort j'ai pas encore
parler toi là je parle des flammes ont
détruit
déjà c'est une preuve bon il ya dans la
lecture des flottes de la dent like you
frériste de l'islam
quelque chose qui s'appelle l'art de la
dissimulation par payer en arabe
tu connais il parle arié que je peux je
suis bilingue montrem ça j'ai pas de
passe est très grave c'est pas français
s'adressait par asi c'est très français
par les gaulois france des militants au
quai d'orsay on a des arabisants
extraordinaire et ailleurs aussi et donc
alors à les gens allaient ou non on
enchaîne donc les lectures frais vis de
l'islam bientôt ils s'appellent latakia
c'est le l'art de la dissimulation
la question que je voudrais poser ce
soir c est ce que tu n'as pas enrichi
cette notion du métier d'humoriste
c'est à dire qu'à travers le métier
d'humoriste pour nous tu pratiques une
sorte de taqiyya et j'ai entendu le
début de l'émission
on voit bien qu'ils étaient toujours
tangente est toujours entre deux hôtes
et toujours c'est toujours très ambigu
ton discours has est parfaitement ça
rentre parfaitement dans la théorie de
sayyed qutb qui est un des grands
intérêts connu l'islam
non mais attends tu la joues pas tu
connais ça dans ma tête ça y est de code
tu connais pas ben pour moi c'est
l'arrière gauche de lille mais ça s'est
passé exactement comme les menaces de
mort que tu reçois par midi mais dont
personne sait lesquels sont mais c'est
quoi la non mais j'en vendrais vantaa
questions auxquelles s'attelait à venir
pour lui poser une caisse que tu
pratiques à travers ton métier
d'humoriste moins une forme
contemporaine de ce que la théorie
frériste
l'islam a fait de la taqiyya oui ou non
la drac a laissé leur est alors juste
pour déconstruire pas ce que c'est
je cherche une première partie si demain
tu es libre aux théâtre de dix heures je
peux te prendre la taqiyya ça serait la
stratégie que les musulmans ils veulent
prendre le pouvoir mais même les
musulmans ils sont pas au courant c'est
un musulman c'est pas d'âge
il me fallait des musulmans j'ai parlé
de même aller au bout mais restée
malaisie namyst mais c'est d'arriver au
catch là des fois il y en a deux défauts
il y en a je finis avec moi tu reviens
je reviens je bats tu kiffes les
octogone on a tu kiffes les octogone ont
alors si tu confonds booba yassine
belattar il faut je suis prêt je suis
hexagone mais je parlais de nos jours je
vais dire que dans les ardennes octobre
d'intellectuels évidemment aller y en a
du talent et d'humour l'asie un humour
je te laisse les racistes alors juste
dire quelque chose hein c'est pas un
mois voilà il s'avère que il y a
quelques mois on s'est vus avec pour
cyril oui et on s'est vus parce que tout
simplement moi je faisais une émission
si on a vu qu'ils s'appellent nova avec
toute l'estimé que j'ai pour radio
orient que les autres radios qui n'est
pas connu pour être une radio
communautaire
donc moi j'ai fait trois race noire les
missions exceptionnelles s'appelle les
trente glorieuses qui est maintenant sur
deezer qui s'appelle l'heure de gloire
toutes les semaines je fais des
émissions et dans mes émissions jeu j'ai
un double discours quand je fais des
vannes avec des mecs qui s'appelle
benjamin tranier avec des mecs qui
s'appelle nabil avec des mecs qui
s'appelle louis mathoux et j'aimerais je
vais te décevoir je sais que tu pars du
principe que j'ai une double un double
discours moi je pars du principe que
certaines personnes comme toi oui ou une
double audition
c'est à dire que c'est toi qui entend
des choses que je n'ai jamais dit j'ai -
jeanne d'arc mais pas à ce point non
mais je sais que c'est le symbole de ton
parti donc respecté juste te dire
qu'elle ne tenait pas compte mais y'a
pas de soucis mais aussi j'en ai pas
honte
juste le jour dire je sais que tu ne
veux pas l'entendre
je peux comprendre que tu est redevable
à la france jean parce que tu es venu
d'un pays autre et ut installés en
france
moi je suis né français bauthian jusqu'à
l'assemblée ils ont fermé ou un cri la
marseillaise carte nationale d'identité
et moi je le vois ta fenêtre une carte
mais où est la nation et où l'identité
mais tu veux quoi que je marque contre
le brésil à saint denis avec zidane sait
c'est fait c'est quoi enfin je mets tu
crois que mais moi je suis français tout
le temps j'ai pas besoin d'un coup de
jeune homme et ça se voit pas juste
aubry 500
dijon vous combattrez jusqu'au bout tous
les gens qui se disent patriotes c'est
un mot que ma génération que ça soit les
jimmy que ce soit karim qui a milité que
ça soit nos grands frères dans les
quartiers que ce soit les frères de la
marche des beurs que ce soit tous ceux
qui lèvent la tête que ça soit cyril
dans sa manière de donner la parole à
certaines personnes que d'autres médias
ne veulent pas invité nous sommes la
france
quand mon grand père tabasser des nazis
le tiers est en train de boire un thé au
caire ou bien j'en étais midi le
gangrène aujourd'hui tu n'en sais rien
non mais je te dis un moment où on nous
a été enrôlé dans l'armée britannique
est là comme battue romaine lors des
deux derniers départs allant pourquoi
toi pour aider la grèce comme bien ce
que je te dis j'en sais qu un moment tu
es là en train de distribuer pardon peut
dire ça tu es l'idiot utile d'un parti
de racine à nantua toi tu es l'idiot et
à réviser d'ici là les objets mais tu
devais prendre la tête de la mairie de
paris pourront certes et pourquoi mais
non mais c'est pas là c'est chiant la
tuer com - man u new look que les un
[ __ ] pas vrai les ch'tis l'objet
c'est parce qu'à l'aspect genre si
jean-luc à paris georges europe le
rassemblement national ne fait pas de
score c'est une campagne qui coûte cher
mais on ne peut pas prendre le risque de
faire une campagne qui est coutumière
chirac pour faire moins de cinq jours
mais c'est juste parce que tous les
électeurs de barbès et je ne sais
pourquoi référence je rentre d'une
tournée dans les fédérations du
rassemblement à sanaa où je suis très
bien accueilli par les militants - je
sais bien comment y avait dedans mais je
t'invite l'arabe louncény nabé la
recherche de mettre à lyon je vais
travail je vais sera permis aux nous
viens avec moi et je ne te revient à
thomas bach mai via media sales huard et
après tu verras comment méchant je suis
accueilli la vérité c'est qu'au
rassemblement national il n'y a pas de
racistes il ya des enveloppes 120m
péninsule qui ne sont pas pures et voilà
racistes au front national
non non en fait des guerres lancées sur
la zonda tantôt mais oui mais ça c'est
ça c'est toi qui es raciste en disant ça
mais ça c'est pas la france mais
simplement mais sa part la france c'est
bien si les caméras
yacine j'ai juste une question à te
poser tu dis que tu vas te battre contre
des remarques sur jean alors est-ce que
ce même discours
tu le tiendrait au maroc s'il y avait
une minorité chrétienne par exemple au
juive au maroc avec un type qui
s'appellerait yassine belattar local
mais qui ouvre arrière ou un prénom
plutôt un nom plutôt chrétiens qui se
balade avec une croix comme toi tu te
balades à barbe et qui tient le même
discours que toi par les porter ça là
c'était le premier au maroc a critiqué
cette personne est à dire il faut
défendre l'identité marocaine
alors pourquoi est-ce que tu acceptes
dans ton pays dans le pays d'origine de
tes parents tu le refusa la france
pourquoi est-ce que tu qualifies de
nationalisme de patriotisme et tous les
encourage dans tous les pays de la terre
pourquoi tu veux l'interdire la france
mais moi ça ça y est tu as fini la pizza
a mis tous les ingrédients mais a buté
il m'a dit pas bonjour laisser leur
répondent cette fois c'est aller vers
les gens moi je suis content de te voir
je sais pas toi tu sais pas s'il attend
je sais pas quand je te parle si tu te
sens islamisés avec les frères musulmans
non non moi je suis un frêne je suis
immunisé de longue date chez round
absolument être là si j'arrive à voir
d'autres questions parce qu'on va
libérer ya si je suis né en france
j'aime la france j'aime vraiment la
france d'accord je suis père de famille
tout ça ça te dépasse quand je te dis
combat que les patriots et qu' il a
fallu se battre longtemps et karine
qu'une coupe si j'ai tort vous nous avez
préempter des mots patriotisme drapeau
on ne pouvait même pas se revendiquer
dans la porte en a fait les frais dans
les quartiers aujourd'hui
pendant longtemps le symbole du drapeau
était un symbole qui nous renvoyait
quelque part au front national
je suis un battant je vais au bout mais
c'est juste parce que je suis désolé
tapez wikipédia fait descendre la souris
avant marine le pen y avait un mec qui
s'appelait jean marie le pen d'accord
donc un moment jean marie le pen pardon
de te dire ça il a fait des choses
en tout cas à une partie des français
qui sont de confession musulmane ou
autres qui ont fait qu'on sait pas tout
de suite senti encore pour réparer mais
je finissais juste quelque chose
moi j'ai un choc émotionnel politique
pour répondre à eric naulleau de manière
tout à fait bienveillant que je vais
vous dire quelque chose avec nono moi je
suis né en 80 de mon choc émotionnel
politique qui fait que un jour j'ai
décidé de m'engager rose or on l'a
quasiment le même âge donc on fait
partie de ce choc c'est qu'un jour je me
suis réveillé en avril 2002 j'ai allumé
télé il y avait jean marie le pen et là
je me suis dit yacine soit tu continues
à fermer ta gueule
dans une france parallèle et tu passes
ta vie à dire ouais la france ceci cela
soit tu fais en sorte de faire mon parti
une composante de ce pays là tout ce que
je fais je le bris au nom de la france
mais maintenant c'est marrant je ne
t'entends jamais proclamé ta fierté
d'être français comme je t'en es ce que
ces fiers d'être français de l'année
avec attendant ils avaient besoin soient
jetés jouer le match allons enfants jeux
attend souvent proclamer avec verve et
faconde la fierté de ses origines
jamais je ne t'entends proclamé français
méritants garcia mais elle à tapas jamel
debbouze devant toi hein j'ai acheté 10
kg
moi je vais est morte d origine en bon
doublé le parent et je suis la france et
je suis mais juste si tu me suis sur
twitter ou le maintien beaucoup d'états
tête a courageusement verrouillé c'est
le tonnerre le but de suivre ton armée
de clones la star wars je te dis jusqu'à
maintenant les rues léger léger les
maires à ton service de ton côté hockey
youssef ben brik un journaliste qui est
enfermé jusqu'à il ya très très peu de
temps au maroc a été un journaliste a
été enfermé pour un tweet concernant ce
qui s'est passé au real dans le rif
marocain je peux dire que c'est pas trés
marocain est très soutien du pouvoir que
de tweets et libéré ne se battre je suis
très fier moi je pense
et pour te dire à quel point je suis
beaucoup plus progressiste que toi comme
les notions de france précise sans rien
dire ok bombardiers russes ainsi tu as
largement régressé histoire ainsi
aujourd'hui la discussion elle et moi je
suis pas pour les partis
je trouve que la gauche nous a acculé
dans une espèce de biens weiland
bienveillance mais le à nous donner des
gymnases d'accord avec du kkr et du
manga en dix ans c'est ça la france ou
non il s'avère que être français c'est
complexe il ya des mecs de quartiers qui
sont des libéraux des chefs d'entreprise
comme des mecs de quartiers qui sont des
communistes mais jamais qu'ils
manifestent le week end mais jamais ce
que je veux dire par là un jean pour que
tu le comprennent un moment la réalité
c'est pas être français c'est pas le
dire c'est comme avec les femmes et je
sais pas comment tu es avec ta femme
dire je t'aime c'est pas une preuve lui
montrer tous les jours c'est différent
et c'est de faire mais voilà c'est passé
parce que des c'est parce que dit la
théorie à laquelle tend à laquelle tu
pratiques et tu connais toi mais je
connais la blague il a dû rentrer chez
toi le soir hba ta femme si elle sait
pas pourquoi toi tu le sais si toi tu
sais pas pourquoi elle le sait alors
s'abstenait ça non non non j'ai pas
compris la blague
juste qu'il sera demain dans la grosse
rigolade c'est ça c'est ça les vannes
que tu fais à marseille on sait les
vannes qui permet moi je suis pas
humoriste en live